because more than 20 climate groups have
launched a campaign today aimed at
banning advertising by fossil fuel
companies across the eu in a similar way
to the ban on tobacco advertising
implemented nearly 20 years ago in the
uk so tessa should adverts for fossil
fuel companies be banned what's your
take
yeah well look anna as your report made
clear the vast majority of ads by fossil
fuel companies are green washing which
is to say that they are misleadingly
giving the impression that fossil fuel
companies are interested in investing in
green energy and zero carbon solutions
when actually they're doubling down on
investments in oil and gas and
extracting fossil fuels
we also know of course that fossil fuels
are endangering our health and our
rights in the most serious way
imaginable so yeah it's a good idea to
ban fossil fuel advertising um but the
most dangerous i think
effect of these advertisements is that
it's lulling our governments into this
false sense of security that the fossil
fuel industry can be trusted to lead
this transition away from
oil and gas and polluting sources of
energy and i think the uk government has
fallen into that trap as we've seen in
the deal that it struck with oil and gas
companies here in the uk in the form of
the north sea transition deal which is a
voluntary framework with incredibly weak
targets um so you know the the oil and
gas lobby in the uk is already accessing
the government in all kinds of ways it
certainly doesn't also
need the opportunity to advertise as
well do you think that's right james i
mean the the analogy that's been made is
with the tobacco industry which have has
had adverts banned
what do you make of this i mean fossil
fuel companies will say we want to be
able to communicate with our customers
what do you think
well i've got to ask tessa whether she's
ever clicked on a banner ad because i
never had and i never have met anybody
who's ever looked at an internet banner
ad now i've also got to ask tessa in the
nicest possible way have you read this
book it's published in 1957 and it said
uh the advertising you know was very
influential with people have you read
this book it's published in 1963 by
marshall mcluhan saying that the medium
is the the message and the advertising
is very influential advertising is not
influential
the plebs as green people like to
imagine the population at large do not
buy advertising they don't accept what
advertising says because they got more
brains than greens credit them with it's
all part of the class just come back at
that very quickly
yeah i mean i guess you'd wonder then
why it is that fossil fuel companies are
plowing hundreds of millions of pounds
into advertising if it's so ineffective
and they have managed to
keep a hold on our power system okay um
and our power supply despite all we have
to leave it there i'm leaving that i'm
leaving the last
shrug and shake up the head there with
james we haven't got time to hear from
your mom frey but we must leave it there
thank you both very much indeed
you